Oh
how's it going browses welcome to
firewood stuff online don't know what to
give your friends for Christmas don't
worry I got your back
I've collected some of the worst things
you could possibly give your friends
you're welcome item number one head cage
yes
head cake whatever hey hey head [ __ ]
head case head case it's apparently a
little game you can play with yourself
if you don't have any friends this is
the game for you apparently look how
much fun they're having quite oh [ __ ]
you lions okay this looks super
elaborate what it I don't like I don't
like this already
not a fan oh whatever the [ __ ] yeah I'm
sure I can figure this out again for
[ __ ] sake you piece of [ __ ] you're
trash the [ __ ] is all this how does it
look
I feel like that lady that shoots ping
pong balls out of her all right how many
do you think I'm gonna get here we go
didn't get that one
this is a lot harder than it looks but
am I having fun oh boy well could
possibly beat item number one item
number two this is probably why you
clicked on this video if you're
discussing with your friends what a boob
feels like let me just say it doesn't
get closer than this I would say just
get really fat and touch your own boobs
and it's pretty much the same this is
something very thorough Petach about
this Oh God Oh
nightmares ah why am I keep doing this
yeah it really feels like a bag of sands
do it come on come on I am your mother
do it alright great item item number 3
however alright alright Bryce I'm gonna
be honest I'm running out of ideas so
we're gonna combine two items together
cuz that I've been I've been away
alright there's a lot to catch up on I
didn't have time to find it takes time
to give you the best of the market you
ready
hypno glasses I know what you're
thinking hilarious but wait let's
combine this item with 100% pain
I feel like a hundred percent pain
that's it that's a pretty good
percentage of pain that I want to
experience for the first time yeah it
smells like pure whoa it smells like
pure death Oh 60 million scholar vials
that's pretty high
cheers bro Oh
well
I got him sweating
Oh God
huh
[ __ ] you
whoa whoa aah
Oh potato balls man [ __ ] me okay I'm
sorry go let's mean I'm weighted 84
years sir our wonderful gift what wow
thank you sponsor you go [ __ ]
lootcrate each month loot crate sends a
package with a new theme
someone's theme is time this is code
from the future I'm here to say that I
made a confusion the box that I'm
opening is for October its time but
November's box is going to be combat
combat which will be items from The
Hunger Games blizzard and fallout 4
fallout 4 that's all I need to know baby
ok I hope this cleared up some confusion
purged from the future
[ __ ] awesome pop a figure of dr.
Emmett Brown from Back to the Future I
love these pops [ __ ] [ __ ] they should do
a youtuber edition I think that'd be
awesome
fabulous t-shirt a hoverboard it better
be a hoverboard and of course there is
actually a pretty [ __ ] cool hover
book hahaha
that is awesome yeah a real hammer board
oh wow okay I don't watch Doctor Who but
I know like half my audience is gonna
freak out it's a cool fork oh it's a
sport egg of course
haha hilarious haha alright really cool
items this week if you like packages
everyone let's be honest everyone loves
packages and you can get one every month
to you loot crate calm sighs periods to
get 10% off it supports the show I
really appreciate it thank you so much
for everyone it's been great getting
great feedback and appreciate it thank
you loot crate calm slash boots and to
the code pills get 10% off there we go I
am just told right now by the producer
Matthew McConaughey that there is two
another combo item what is the combo
Matthew oh shoot toilet paper
but Matthew what's so special about
aller paper it glows in the dark it
glows in the dark but how does it
combine I can play basketball in the
computer my stomach really hurts from
that pain thing don't don't do it
alright just watch me do it okay slam
dunk slam dunk ah hilarious alright well
this is a little awkward but I'm ready
and oh oh oh no I can't see the toilet
paper can you see it it's totally I can
totally see it it's so bad it's like it
works it works good here it just this is
really awkward isn't it umm it goes for
me but the camera is not picking up on
it but I am let me just say that
I'm wiping my ass right now let's try
one more
Wow look at this one that's it for this
week's by weight stuff online thank you
for watching and remember to check out
loot crate come slash boots really
appreciate you supporting the show I
love doing these episodes Edgar what do
you have to say about these episodes can
I suck your own Apple again yes you can
but once we're done with the episode
thumbs up this video if you like to be
naked in your own home and I'll see you
in the next one
brofist look you like Fitz oh I could be
a I could be an animal model this is fun
hahahaha